hello everybody just wanted to make a
quick feel on the news story that aired
today is available on their website so
click a link in the description below to
go to my Cincinnati local 12 news site
you'll see the article there there's a
full transcript and the video itself is
in the left hand side you can see it's
click on it you can watch it there I
can't host it here so I just have to
link directly to it so thank you guys so
much for doing this I mean I wouldn't
have a story on the news if it wasn't
for you guys you guys have really helped
me out and done an amazing thing with
our charity drives I'm just I'm so proud
of you guys in what we've done together
so thank you guys so much
um just it's unbelievable to know that
this is happening I'm I'm ecstatic and
this means that next time when we do
this in the beginning of March we'll
have an even bigger showing we'll get
even more support and we'll raise even
more money so thank you guys again so
much and please watch the video too and
below it shows a little bit of why this
charity is important to me I've
discussed it over the charity livestream
before but this helps get in a more
personal way so thank you guys again and
now oh and one more thing in the article
they say that I'm the fastest growing
YouTube gaming channel in YouTube
history
I'm not I just wanted to make that very
clear I'm not so that's a little bit of
Correction I'm flattered that they think
I am but not quite there yet so thank
you guys again remember in the
description click that link right there
at the top so thanks again guys you guys
have done so much to change my life in
together I know we're gonna do
incredible things so thank you again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]